[Music]
every week we are given new Intel after
taking out the Nemesis in The Descent
game mode this video will be a
continuation of the last video where I
covered off the first four comms if you
haven't seen it I'd highly suggest
checking it out first as it will be
referring to it throughout the link
should be in the top right hand corner
however here's a quick rundown of what
was discovered it is based in a Time
long before the outbreak likely years
Calvin McManus and Natalia Sokolova are
talking to Alexander and Claire Ortiz
about a new piece of tech they have
created three different AI systems
one of which is Isaac
Natalia isn't completely sold on the
take of the stage as she has concerns
around the amount of data it gathers
however it would appear she eventually
buys into it later on as a black task
can be seen sporting the logo of one of
the AIS called Diamond
however in the background Claire Ortiz
does not trust Natalia and is providing
Kelvin with more advanced access to all
three of these systems
now I have big plans for this system of
yours that's excellent Cal
if I wanted to utilize your system for
three organizations would I need to wear
three of those watches and three of
those bricks or could you put all three
on a single unit for me
I'm not sure what you mean
I'm looking at your technology and I see
other organizations who could benefit
from these tools the NSA is just the tip
of the iceberg when it comes to
intelligence and security I have other
more obscure teams at my disposal who
could utilize this technology it would
increase my order tenfold and give you
and the misses plenty of seed money to
play around with more private
contractors not at all Homeland Security
strictly Homeland and governmental
entities and they all fall under your
purview of course I am the secretary if
you're looking for a more
discrete single unit we could house all
three on a single system and you decide
which system you want to access through
the interface can you get rid of the
brick for me for just you or for you in
all the field agents just me
I think it's helpful to have the
identification on the back the risk can
be a little hard to see but that Beacon
of Hope in the dark illuminating your
face
there's something heroic about that
[Laughter]
following on from some of the earlier
columns Calvin McManus is further
personalizing the tech he is getting
as the Secretary of Homeland Security he
will have access to all three AI systems
and will be able to shift between them
with ease using his watch
he's also able to use this without the
bulky brick that the agents in the Black
Tusk have
this looks like it's the same for
Natalya and the diamond AI
the other entities he's talking about
that are under his umbrella I can only
assume this includes the hunters but
they don't typically have a brick or
watch either well I mean other than the
ones that display across the chest
perhaps this more subtle version of
wielding the AI becomes more widely used
later on
detected hostile eliminated
what do you think I think this is a
waste of time
it's just for the field test I promise
if the results come back and they prefer
Anna we can delete Isaac if we're just
going to delete it all I don't see the
point in wasting time building an
entirely separate AI we could be
investing this time in refining Anna
instead of building a Superfluous backup
they've requested a more impersonal AI
for the field test did they request it
or did you ask them to request it you
know how they are fine but Isaac is not
going to be as smart or independent as
Anna I don't have time to do all that
reprogramming and recording he will have
to be very binary in his morality if
you're fine with an AI that doesn't get
nuanced well Adam is an option
I think the users will feel more
comfortable with a less human sounding
AI Anna can be a little much you learn a
little much I don't like how humans he
is sometimes
eliminate or sedate she's hilarious and
she gives you choices you're telling me
you would rather have direct orders from
an AI than operational Choice I'm
telling you I don't think people are
ready for an AI that can pass the
touring test
well we know where the voice of Isaac
came from Alexander Ortiz and clear
voices Anna not that this really means
much but it does a little bit show which
each of them favor kind of
this piece is good because it actually
confirms that Anna as one of the three
AI that was being talked about in one of
the first comms I mean I assumed this in
the previous video but this wasn't
actually specifically mentioned up until
now
however what is more interesting is this
line but Isaac is not going to be as
smart or independent as Anna he will
have to be very binary in his morality
so Isaac is essentially a dumbed down
version of Anna
Anna Anna gives options and sounds like
it can take in a lot more detail around
the scenario at hand before making a
call
I've spoken about Isaac's limitations a
lot over the years and how it has
actually held the division back due to
its seemingly linear and one-dimensional
understanding of right and wrong
I feel like there have been a number of
situations over the months where agents
have been forced to go Rogue even though
they were doing the right thing it just
wasn't understood by Isaac
it makes me wonder how many good agents
have been killed just because they were
flagged Rogue by Isaac also how many
ditched their gear because they're a
flagged however I guess this wouldn't
matter Isaac would still be able to
identify them without their division
gear
so I guess the question is how much of
this could have been avoided if the
division were using Anna rather than
Isaac
and if Kelvin was given these options
why would he pick Isaac unless this was
the whole idea
they are the soldiers on the ground the
last line of defense
they have complete autonomy reporting
only to the president when activated
maybe Kelvin wanted to make sure that
there was something greater than what
they had
so he could control or overpower them if
things got out of hand
there were a lot of people who were
concerned about how much power division
agents are given once activated
Rick velasi was probably the most vocal
so was Calvin holding enter aside just
in case he needed to remove the division
does this mean that the hunters are
using Anna
it would explain why their text seems
ever so slightly stronger than else
but what about Keener in his Rogue
Network why haven't we seen much from
them regarding Anna since Theo hacked
into it and technically we have kenner's
watch while it certainly gave us some
updates why don't we have Anna talking
to us
sir I wanted to follow up about that
professor in New York what Professor
Amherst his student was trying to seduce
him so
leave with her no sir so your update is
there is no update not exactly I don't
care about some college professor is
there a problem with the Isaac system no
the comms are still coming in there's
still too much data to sort through but
I think we might want to take a closer
look at this professor sleeping with a
different student no sir he's been
giving lectures about viruses resetting
the world to curb climate change so Kook
or a dangerous expert in virology who
could help nature along
firstly Kelvin is an ass
secondly this is a direct response to a
piece of Intel recovered in one of the
classified assignments that were
available not long after the division 2
released
this particular mission was called NSA
site B13
tasked with uncovering the source of an
urgent NSA security alert agents make
their way to a facility that is based
underneath the National Mall
that's so interesting Professor
long-term survival depends on evolution
the common cold used to cold a week
those who survived were stronger and
went on to breed the Next Generation and
so on Darwin sure but you see we
short-circuited this Evolution we
developed drugs that keep those who
should have died from dying we've
artificially propped up the week for
over a century so what's the answer
eugenics
not at all
I don't think we should have any choice
in who lives and who dies Humanity can't
be trapped with those decisions people
will always find a way to gain the
system to capitalize on it to commodify
it like big Pharma exactly an entire
industry devoted to keeping sick people
artificially alive in order to exploit
them the more pills you take the more
money they make more people overcrowd
the planet and more people pollute the
world it's not sustainable you're right
it's not
yeah kind of a genius I'm just a guy who
sees the big picture
Stacy Chan engages in the conversation
with Professor Gordon Amherst who
expresses his belief in the disruption
of Natural Evolution due to Modern
medicine's ability to prolong the lives
of the week
they discuss the dangers of human
intervention the exploitation of the
pharmaceutical industry and the
unsustainable consequences of a crowded
and polluted world
in this exchange Amherst sees himself as
someone who perceives the broader
perspective on these matters this
particular recording is labeled as
Gordon Amherst recording 118 so the NSA
had been watching him for a while
based on a lot of the other columns that
have been released through descent this
was long before he created the green
poison years before
given how long the NSA have been
watching him was this the moment Bill
told not to continue monitoring him was
Calvin the one directly responsible for
ignoring all the signs in Intel that had
been gathered on Amherst and leaving him
to continue his work undisturbed
is he that daft
or was this on purpose
there have been several mentions from
earlier on that allude to Amherst being
pointed in the right direction by those
with ties to the government
is this where Kelvin comes in or is he
just an ass
I'm loving these comms while they're
based on years before the outbreak so
far they're answering a lot of our
questions from earlier on I mean not
completely I still have a ton of
follow-up questions but we're only
halfway through the Descent cons or are
we the total number has changed a few
times now anyway I like how some of
these gaps in the story from years ago
are starting to be filled in
in summary Kelvin McManus continues to
personalize his access to all AI systems
effectively making him the overlord of
all three
Anna has now been confirmed as one of
the AI that Ortiz robotics have created
and is in fact Superior to Isaac as far
as independent functionality goes
and last but not least it would seem
that the NSA had been falling close
attention to Gordon Amherst long before
he created the dollar flew but Kelvin
seems to be the person who stopped them
from watching him
by the time this video comes out there
will have been another one of these
comms released number eight these videos
can take me a little while to put
together so there can often be some
overlap
come the end of these comms I'll
probably put a compilation together of
the Lord of them removing some of the
waffle for people that come across these
later
but for now what do you think of these
comms Have you listened to them and come
up with different conclusions to what
was happening
let everyone know in the comments
if you have made it this far you're
likely among the thousands of nerds like
myself who like to speculate on this
stuff I don't always reply but I love
seeing the different directions people
take the Intel that is released through
the story
anyway as always thank you very much for
watching and extremist malice extrema
remedia
[Music]
[Applause]